hi I'm Rebecca Angelou I'm Lauren sugar
Blum and I'm Craig Gillespie and today
we're going to share some surprising and
true stories we discovered while making
dumb money
how much should we make today 5 million
how much do we lose today a billion and
yesterday
4 million and yesterday
a billion
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
funds make a ton of money one thing we
discovered while working on this
screenplay for the movie Dumb money was
that Gabe Plotkin the hedge fund guy we
depict really did buy two side-by-side
Mansions On the Waterfront in Miami and
tear down one of them to build a tennis
court for his family during the pandemic
Wall Street must be seeing this right
you should probably dial in one
surprising thing that is also true that
I love that's in the movie is that Vlad
tenev and beijubat who founded Robin
Hood actually do have matching Teslas
which you see them Drive in the film
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the Game Stop
situation
one thing that uh popped up late in the
game was uh it was so an article that
Steve Cohen actually had a pig a pet pig
that lived in their house for about 10
years I think it was until it got too
big to be at the mansion and they and
they put it out on a farm so it was like
that has to be in the movie GameStop
those shares Non-Stop and no stop it's
only going to go up when they hit I'm
gonna buy you a mansion let's drink to
that my brother is a nerd surprising but
true Kevin Gill Keith Gill's brother
really did according to his College
Newspaper run a mile naked during a
lightning storm which is depicted at the
end of our movie with Pete David so stay
until the end because there's a great
great scene there you have to testify
before Congress the game has changed a
lot of people feel the system is broken
the whole idea of the stock market is if
you're smart and maybe with a little
luck you can make your fortune I think
one you know really great part of the
hearing that is true is when AOC dresses
down Vlad time about the commissions on
Robin Hood and really goes for it there
it's a great great moment and just to
see her break down the logic of what
free trading is on Robin Hood was
wonderful to see it's also a moment when
Keith Gill really opened up and talked
about his family life his background his
experiences and about what people were
going through during the pandemic which
is really the the gist of our film so it
was powerful I think to see him speak
from the heart the way he did something
thousand people have watched this video
[Music]
if he's in I'm in if he's in I'm in our
very own director Craig Gillespie lost
money how'd you do crack yeah I don't
think it's a surprise that I lost money
uh my son was uh involved early on in
this uh in Wall Street bats movement and
he was doing extremely well with it and
timed it perfectly he warned me about
getting in and and I sort of timed it
perfectly right before Robin Hood put
the freeze on the buy option so right
before the the price yes bought high and
sold low he's a he's a better director
than investor thankfully yo what up
everybody roaring Kitty here I'm gonna
pick a stock and talk about why I think
it's interesting and that stock is game
starts I love this guy I think it was
surprising that he's a star athlete
right you think of someone who's this
good at the stock market as on their
computer all the time and not physical
and that he had this big running career
was shocking and he also was like a
champion at this card game he toured
Europe as a teenager playing this card
game that he's great at he Keith is one
of those guys who just kind of touched I
think uh throughout his life he's been
gifted at one thing or another the
GameStop story is just the latest
example I mean within the GameStop story
I was surprised at like the darkest
moment uh in the trading where Wall
Street bets was shut down for 48 hours
and then with the Robin Hood situation
that happened with the buy option and he
was offline and people waiting to see
what he did that he didn't sell yeah
that was a surprise to me that he
actually in that 48 Hours lost 30
million dollars in still hell and that
caused a whole nother rally yeah he's a
man of such conviction yeah and also
someone who was you know doesn't seek
Fame doesn't sensitive to really care
about money you know he's very very
admirable in all those ways
everything okay
11 million dollars what are you gonna do
get a Ferrari what the oh language
the baby's here Danner is such a
brilliant actor he's such nuance and
complexity like everything that he does
in such range the year before he was
doing Batman I was a very very dark
character and the fablements at the same
time oddly for me they were all that got
me excited for this was uh Swiss army
man and there was this sort of
exuberance and naivety to that
performance that I felt elements of in
in the post that Keith Gill would do
it's like it's such a hard thing to
become the focal point and the rallying
cry for the online community they're
very skeptical and cynical and quick to
cut you down and there is this
earnestness in this uh authentic nature
to Keith Gill's videos that inspired
eight million people to like following
these coattails Paul had to capture that
and that's no easy feat as an actor and
to be able to do that balance and have
that nuance
to like you know inspire people and feel
like it's genuine it's like I think his
game was like way out I guess yeah and
he captured so many great true moments
like when roaring Kitty actually dipped
a chicken tender in champagne and you
know it talked about the stock he just
he did it exactly like right and kitty
really did and you know with the writing
that these guys did they were very true
true to what was actually written and so
and and so was Paul he was the Game
Keeper of like hey I saw that he said
this in a video clip could we try and
use that could we get that in here
somewhere you know he really really dug
in deep on the research I would say
Craig is brilliant at a listening
nuanced performances from actors and you
see it performed one way and you're like
oh that's genius and then and then he'll
he'll do another cut and it's it's a
totally different way and it's also
genius Paul was acting alone in a lot of
these scenes I mean he was just talking
to an online audience and to see so much
emotion and so much depth in his
performance when he doesn't even have
um an actor to play against was
incredible